und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend ihnen allen die Bundeswehr
ist wie eine ausgepresste Zitrone und
man soll nicht glauben dass aus den
Überbleibseln wieder eine Zitrone wird
wenn man Fruchtsaft im Wert von 100
Milliarden reinpumpt so hat das ein
deutscher rüstungsmanager dieser Tage
gesagt da muss man abziehen dass der
Mann natürlich seine Waffen verkaufen
will aber dennoch bleibt eine
schonungslos verheerende
Zustandsbeschreibung übrig die wir im
Kopf haben sollten gerade heute an einem
Tag an dem der Bundestag grünes Licht
gegeben hat für milliardenschwere
aufrüstungsprojekte darunter F35
tarnkappenflieger aus den USA die der
Hersteller als tödlichsten Kampfjet der
Welt ein Preis Christian hübscher
das wird er sein der neue Kampfjet der
Bundeswehr die amerikanische F35
Tarnkappe ist atombombenfähig und gehört
zum abschreckungskonzept der NATO die
Verteidigungsministerin zuletzt auch aus
der Ampel kritisiert bekommt heute vom
Bundestag das Go 35 Flugzeuge kann sie
nun bestellen innerhalb von neun Monaten
ist dieses Projekt jetzt so weit
gebracht worden dass heute der Vertrag
unterzeichnet werden konnte ich glaube
das ist schon eine Rekordzeit der
Opposition geht alles trotzdem nicht
schnell genug vom 2% Ziel der NATO sei
Deutschland immer noch weit entfernt so
die Union und vergisst dabei zu erwähnen
dass sie die Bundeswehr selbst jahrelang
kaputt Sparte ihre
Verteidigungsministerin organisiert
anstatt der zeitenwände die Zeiten
Verschwendung das hat mit Fortschritt
nichts zu tun auch 120.000 neue
Sturmgewehre bekommt die Bundeswehr und
20000 Digitalfunkgeräte damit sind die
ersten 15 Milliarden des Sondervermögens
verplant wie überfällig all das ist
zeigt ein geheimer Bericht aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium geht es um
Deutschlands nato-verpflichtungen sei
die Einsatzbereitschaft oft nur
eingeschränkt sichergestellt das heißt
trotz der 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
die er ein wirklich großer Schluck aus
der Pole sind um die Bundeswehr wie der
Moderne auszurüsten werden wir nicht um
hinkommen auf Dauer den wir Etat
deutlich zu erhöhen um unseren
Verpflichtungen nachzukommen doch noch
braucht die Bundeswehr weiter Geduld
denn wirklich einsatzfähig werden diese
neuen Kampfjets hierzulande erst 2028
sein
auch 20.000 moderne Funkgeräte sollen
jetzt angeschafft werden in der
Vergangenheit hatten sich deutsche
Truppen die von anderen Armeen ausleihen
müssen um gemeinsame Einsätze nicht zu
Gefährten auch beim Kampf gegen die
organisierte Kriminalität hat der Staat
in der Vergangenheit ja häufiger den
Eindruck hinterlassen im Grunde einfach
aufzugeben dieser Eindruck soll sich
ändern bei einer großrats ja heute in
mehreren Bundesländern ging es um
verschwundene Autos und den Verdacht auf
groß angelegten Betrug mit corona-hilfen
auch ein
schlagzeilenträchtiger Clan bekam Besuch
von der Polizei Thomas münden
wieder einmal klingelte heute morgen bei
vielen türkischen und arabischen
Familien wie er in Solingen in ganz NRW
Hessen und Niedersachsen überraschend
die Polizei eine großrazia gegen
insgesamt 57 Männer darunter auch solche
die zum libanesischen all seinen Clan
gehören acht Beschuldigte wurden
umgehend festgenommen
Hintergrund sind umfangreiche und
intensiv bisher verdeckt der
Ermittlungen des LKAs der
Staatsanwaltschaft und der
Steuerfahndung in zwei getrennten
Ermittlungsverfahren zum einen dreht es
sich um Autodiebstähle und Hehlerei im
großen Stil zum anderen um
Subventionsbetrug in Millionenhöhe hier
gibt es 40 Beschuldigte
auch diese Beschuldigten gründeten
offenbar Scheinfirmen und er gaunerten
Corona Soforthilfen nach derzeitigem
Erkenntnissen wurde das Geld dann ins
Ausland transferiert ein weiterer Schlag
gegen die Clan Kriminalität in NRW
sieben kleinmitglieder darunter auch
mehrere Frauen stehen derzeit in
Düsseldorf vor Gericht in drohen langer
Haftstrafen wegen Geiselnahme betrug
Diebstahl und Körperverletzung der Clan
ist seit 1982 in Deutschland aktiv 2014
hatten mehrere Mitglieder das KaDeWe in
Berlin überfallen und dabei Schmuck im
Wert von rund 800 000 € erbeutet die
Täter wurden gefasst zum Clan gehören
nach Angaben des Landeskriminalamtes NRW
und zwar 230 aktiven Straftäter der
kleinen Chef Flo 2021 in die Türkei um
eine Abschiebung zu entgehen
ein Preis für 43 Millionen Menschen das
Europaparlament ehrte die die seit zehn
Monaten versuchen müssen dem Raketen
Terror des russischen angriffskriegs zu
entkommen die in ihren Städten und
Dörfern jetzt vielfach ohne Strom in
eisiger Kälte aushaben der
Sacharow-Preis für Menschenrechte geht
an die ukraineische Bevölkerung die
Reportage dazu jetzt nicht vom Festakt
in Straßburg sondern von der Front in
der Region an der Brühl
ein Feuerwehrauto ist kaputt das Gebäude
schwer beschädigt wir sind beim
Rettungsdienst der Ukraine in tourettena
fünf Kilometer entfernt von der Front
kaum sind wir da fängt der Beschuss an
so heftig dass wir zusammen mit den
Männern vom Rettungsdienst erstmal in
den Programm müssen
in der Nähe einschlägt was vorkommt dann
wackeln hier die Wände
André kommt von hier hat sechs Monate
unter russischer Besatzung gelebt seine
Kollegen und er haben damals einfach
weitergemacht
falls es ruhiger wird fahren wir raus in
den Ort mehr als die Hälfte der Häuser
ist zerstört nur wenige sind geblieben
so wie diese alte Frau die in den
Trümmern ihres Nachbarhauses nach
Brennholz sucht
ich weiß nicht was wir machen werden wir
brauchen Holz das Haus steht wir haben
ein Dach
Andreas Frau ist in der Westukraine dort
ist es weniger gefährlich
ja das stimmt aber meine Frau ist
schwanger und das Baby fängt an sich im
Bauch zu bewegen und ich bin hier
und er wird bleiben weitermachen beim
Rettungsdienst der Ukraine
und im Blick auf weitere wichtige
Nachrichten von heute hast jetzt du
Hannah laut Bundeskanzler Scholz hat
sich russlands Präsident Putin mit dem
ukrainekrieg fundamental verrechnet das
sagte Scholz in seiner
Regierungserklärung und versprach der
Ukraine außerdem weitere Hilfen
finanziell und militärisch
Oppositionsführer März forderte Scholz
auf Kampf und Schützenpanzer an die
Ukraine zu liefern
im Bundestag ging es heute eine Woche
nach der großrazia gegen die
Reichsbürger außerdem um die Bedrohung
durch die Gruppierung bis auf die AFD
warnten alle Parteien vor einer
Verharmlosung Innenministerin väser will
als Konsequenz unter anderem das
Waffenrecht verschärfen stößt damit aber
bei der FDP auf Widerstand
rund sechs Monate vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl in der Türkei ist
gegen den Bürgermeister Istanbuls
ihmambolu ein Politikverbot verhängt
worden gilt als möglicher Herausforderer
von Präsident Erdogan ein Gericht
verurteilte den chp-politiker wegen
Beamtenbeleidigung außerdem zu einer
Haftstrafe von zwei Jahren und 7 Monaten
die US-Notenbank Fett hat erneut den
Leitzins angehoben allerdings mit 0,5%
Punkten weniger stark als bei den
letzten Zinsschritten die Fett schlägt
also einen etwas moderateren Kurs ein
zuletzt hatte sich die Inflation in den
USA abgeschwächt die Lottozahlen lauten
10 30 32 43 46 48 Superzahl 3 alle
Angaben ohne Gewähr
der Deutsche Wetterdienst ward aktuell
vor Glatteis in Teilen Süddeutschlands
und frostig geht es auch weiter morgen
im Süden anfangs noch Schnee oder
gefrierender Regen mit Glättegefahr an
der See kräftige Schneeschauer sonst
meist freundlich bei -4 bis plus 4 Grad
am Freitag im Süden weiterer Schnee
sonst ruhiges Wetter teils mit Sonne
aber sehr kalt
das war unser kurzes heute journal in
der Fußballpause viel Spaß jetzt in der
zweiten Hälfte und einen schönen Abend
noch
[Musik]